all right elijah hey how are you welcome
back
i'm back you uh you're still alive
uh surprisingly yeah i've heard a lot of
things
going on yeah i hear your name mentioned
a lot down here since since
since you've arrived you showed up yeah
and got in hot water right from the
get-go even before the video
right yeah even before the video yeah
because you were you you owed a lot of
money to a lot of people
yeah yeah i uh i uh started out here
uh on on on a really rough rough edge
getting getting fronts right from the
get-go not having the money to pay for
it
and uh
and it wasn't it wasn't to play people
initially i
had the understanding i was going to
have the funds to cover it
and then i ended up not having them
because you were going to get your
right a stimulus money which ended up
going into my ex's account and then when
she
got my money she said you're not getting
it i'm keeping it and that got you in
trouble yeah yeah i called the irs and
they said take her to small claim
uh you know small claims court couldn't
do that got legal problems back in
nashville
um so uh couldn't have anything to do
with
courts and law enforcement because they
were what kind of stuff happened because
you owe these guys money
uh yeah so they uh the the initially the
first guy that
um i owed money to uh put a hit out on
me
right um actually actually had uh
hit meaning uh he he put out a
word that uh he would pay somebody to
kill me
um was that the one in the tent or the
one that was the one down here in the
tent
and i was shot at i was shot at and uh
um and then another guy uh that was part
of that hit
later that okay that was late at night
early in the morning
still dark following being shot at that
night did you escape
yeah i escaped barely i only because i
jumped into a crowd of people
and they couldn't spot and just shoot
into a crowd but uh
the a guy rode rode down the street uh
with a gun
hanging out um uh and uh trying to get a
good aim at me to shoot me
and i ran up into uh the refresh center
and um there was a crowd of people
standing out there waiting for the
refresh center to open
and uh huh they shoot at you
not that time no because there was a
crowd of people around and uh
they they couldn't get a clear shot at
me um but yeah i've i've
almost ended up dead now twice i've i've
paid for your bus fare
you did twice out of town and yes and
you're still here
well no i've i've i le i didn't leave
the first time i did leave this second
time
and i'm back now um only only to uh
uh handle a tie up a couple loose ends
um and then i've already got my bus to
get paid for back to nashville to
get the hell out of california um and um
and just uh tie up uh my legal problems
and uh just do the time and and be done
with all this mess
this this has been a ride um and i tell
you what uh
um if you have any kind of drug problem
california
la is not the place to go it is if you
want to do drugs because it's on every
single street
every 10 foot um and it's cheap
real cheap and everybody has it and and
and as long as you start off spending
good money
there's everybody wanting in the front
in front you
and then that's going to cause a lot of
people to want to kill you if you don't
pay them back
that's that's kind of where you ended up
yeah so um
so you're going to turn yourself in you
told me i'm turning myself in yeah i'm
i'm
i'm getting my life back in order i
can't do this homeless life i can't do
the drug life i can't do
people wanting to kill me life
you know i plan on going back to
nashville getting my
my legal problems taken care of and uh
from there i'm moving out of state um
relocating to an undisclosed area
um can't put that uh you know it's
starting my life over you know
i have three uh teenage daughters um
whom i've done a really well a really
good job
and uh with and um you know they're
depending on me and
god forbid they never knew any part of
this this part of my life no you don't
um
because it would it would be nightmarish
um uh they
they don't know any bit about this part
of
dad's life um and and
nor does most of my family and friends
uh you know i uh i can't this this has
been so bizarre
so bizarre i have what how does it feel
to go through your life walking the
street without a place to hide
oh my god yeah for your life yeah no i
mean i i there there's been many times
i've been
running and just running and running and
running and
um i'm tired of looking over my shoulder
i mean i'm you know
and uh literally uh one in two people
have a gun here
and uh and uh and everybody's selling
drugs
but one or two people have guns here and
uh
tupac didn't lie to live and die in l.a
um
they will kill you yeah if you have
enemies here you're
you're going to get hot water very
quickly and it doesn't matter if you
want to pay him back
once once you try to rectify the
situation after you've come up with the
money to pay them back
now now it's all because it becomes
principle now it becomes
now you're going to be making an example
out of that's now
[ __ ] the money now you're going to be
made an example out of because now you
made me look like a chump
um you know they they feel uh these guys
feel that i played them
and that was not at all the intention
and i
clearly got off on the wrong foot and uh
this is just not the place to be
um you know uh if you got so you still
owe these guys money
and but you're here yeah but i'm but i'm
leaving
when you walked up today i'm leaving i'm
leaving before dark yeah but when you
walked up to me today you had the covet
mask you had the hat you had sunglasses
oh yeah a completely different
appearance i cleaned up yeah you didn't
even recognize me
right yeah no nobody did so no one's
going to see you right
right i i leave here i'm heading
straight up to the ground bus station
and uh
ain't nobody going to be stupid enough
to run up into the bus station shoo shoo
shoot
that maybe they were i'm sure there are
crazy ones out there enough
that would do that yeah we just i mean
the core of all this problem all these
headaches you've had
is the drugs right yeah the drugs if you
weren't using drugs none of this would
happen
drugs and and money problems yeah with
the money problems they came
came from the drugs yeah drugs drugs
drugs you're buying drugs from guys that
will
kill you if you don't pay him back yeah
so it wasn't the
informant history that you have it was
the money you vote
oh yeah i never even i never heard
anyone speak of that uh
but down here on skid row i don't think
anybody watches no i there there are
there are people
um it's just i i've i've during the last
two weeks that i was here i changed my
name uh three times
to everybody i was meeting uh first it
was uh
elijah then it was uh joshua then it was
josh then it was robbie then it was ron
then it was rob
um and so there's probably about 300
different people out there that know me
by different names
it is a mystery everyone's hiding from
something here now
down here yeah so if you're going home
to nashville
going home to nashville you have a
family there and a family there
but but how much time do you think
you'll be doing a couple years maybe 50
years uh maybe maybe a year i
can consolidate the time because it was
uh
it was uh actually not even i don't know
probably tennessee has a game time um
so you get two for one and if you get a
job then you get even more time knocked
off
um so what were the time four uh
violation probations
two two it was i was on probation in two
counties for misdemeanor
violations um it's legal to smoke weed
in california
i was on probation for weed in tennessee
um in one county and then driving on a
suspended license in another county
um and uh i uh just
ended up doing a year and a half of
probation for driving on suspended
actually almost right right close to two
years of probation
a whole extra year of probation for
driving on a suspended
the whole extra year was simply because
they kept me on probation for an extra
year
trying to get me to pay off my fines and
core costs and i just didn't have the
money
because i was doing drugs so i fell
behind
you've been playing around with drugs
for how long huh you've been playing
around with drugs for how long
um about two and a half three years
three years four years
so you're fairly new at this fairly new
with this yeah i didn't do drugs most of
my life
i raised my kids i had my family life i
done my
you know i mean i smoked weed growing up
um
and i didn't even do that all throughout
my uh
late teens and early uh all through i
didn't do anything at all in my 20s
other than
uh drink a little bit and uh and then i
started smoking marijuana again when i
was like 33 years old um that was the
first time i started doing drugs again
since i was a teenager
um i'm 39 now i didn't start doing drugs
uh hard drugs until me and my ex got
together
which is when i we ended up breaking up
and that's
how i became homeless and all this mess
just really went out of control after i
got
after i became homeless first time
homeless ever
and uh i i i hate it i can't live like
this
yeah i mean what's what's the lesson
you've learned from all this
um i mean unless your street
you ain't street unless you're hood you
ain't hood uh don't don't try to live
this life if you ain't got it in because
it it will it will
um it'll beat you down eventually man it
beats you down i
i i sit there and i i ran from tennessee
thinking
oh yeah this is gonna you know i'm just
gonna you know run for the rest of my
life
over petty [ __ ] misdemeanor probation
you know
uh violations and um it's like it's so
petty and i've went through hell
and it's only been um sin i left
tennessee in
on march 8th got here march 10th
and uh it hasn't was barely been a month
and and [ __ ] this oh my god
[ __ ] nightmare um i'll gladly go do
the i'll probably doing probably seven
or eight months in the county
i did five years in the state
penitentiary and you'll be clean yeah
i'll be cloudy clean
hopefully you stay clean and uh yeah i i
i stick
to marijuana um after this because um
yeah i mean uh go home straighten your
get my life back in order get back to
your kids yeah i mean i've been saying
this is the longest i've been single i
i'm i thrive in relationships i like
working
a nine-to-five job construction making
money legitimately
instead of hustling and man i'm so tired
of
hustling money and lying to uh people
trying to [ __ ] this this i'm not built
for this
i don't know hey i mean i see i see
people out here
man they they are good at that they're
good at this life
and i don't want it i'm not good at it
um
i had a whole different scene in in mind
when i
left tennessee to come to california
california and
um this was not at all it
that's a horrible way but man this sucks
and
uh maybe i'll come visit you in a year
or two yeah
yeah interesting video
hopefully hopefully i'm married uh
remarried by then and uh
starting a new life new job and uh
finished my
finish my my college degree and um
and computer programming and get my life
back get my life back and
and uh you know pick up where i where i
[ __ ] up and left off yeah love to see
that
i will all right elijah thank you so
much thanks man good luck
ask me what the hell are you still doing
here
okay yeah this will be interesting yeah
yeah you're the last person i expected
to see
right
all right elijah hey you're back again
i'm back again this is i think the third
time i've given you money to get out of
town
yeah yeah again you're still here yeah
guys
people are shooting at you yeah shooting
at me and
uh chaos uh consumes me uh i i i hate it
here but i love it here it's um
it just sucks you in here and um uh i uh
can't seem to leave why not is it is it
the
crack is available everywhere no you
know what i mean the drugs is cool you
know it's a
it's readily available um but it's uh
i don't know like i i in and
in part i have a choice to be here and i
think that's what separates me from a
lot of these other people here
is a lot of the people a lot of the
homeless population here
doesn't have a choice to be here they've
made this home
and they've made this their life i have
options
but i choose to stay here i think one
because my legal problem still i just i
don't know if i'm
just not ready to face that but that's
not even really why i'm staying
i just uh every [ __ ] day is exciting
it's it's crazy
it's unpredictable it's frightening it's
exciting
it's uh yeah people get addicted to this
life yeah yeah but i i mean i'm not
gonna i'm not gonna get addicted to
the the the way of life in terms of like
you know homeless and
and staying here in the drugs and um the
fact i one i can't meet a woman i just
they're
um not much of a selection there um
i'm not trying to uh uh
i understand yeah so at any rate um i'm
still here i'm still here
it's dangerous for you it is dangerous
for me because there are
there are people that want to kill me
because you didn't pay off their debts i
didn't pay off some debts
yeah um and uh no matter what
what that looks like no matter how that
occurred it it
is the end result is it's my fault so it
makes you look crazy yeah it makes me
look really stupid
people are going to say it makes me look
even stupider for staying
and it's kind of like cat and mouse and
i'm not trying to run from them but i'm
also not trying to be seen by them
i i know i know like what area of town
not to go in
i know uh what areas to avoid um and
like i'll be walking with some people
i've met and then they'll go
towards that uh certain side of town
they'll like let's turn down this road
let's [ __ ]
not uh let's turn the [ __ ] around in
there
why why do you no just don't no i don't
want to explain let's just not
you know i am constantly giving
explanations if
i don't want to explain and uh but what
do you think keeps you here where it's
dangerous for you uh you know
it's it's the unpredictability it's it's
um
are you self-destructive is it self you
know what i'm i think i think in part i
i think i can i it may be a an excuse so
to speak but i
i think i'm part blaming on my bipolar
and we don't make rational decisions as
people with bipolar disorder
i have a list of mental health diagnoses
that's the leading one
uh along with a number of others and i
think a little you know
with that i don't make rational
decisions and i know i'm like i'm i'm
like
cognitive of the fact that i'm not
making very good decisions right now
um but i can't steer away from it like i
just
you you even left town at one point but
came back i left town i went to
uh well san diego and uh i that at that
point i left because at that point i had
been shot at
and it was actually a bullet went
through my tent
um and i was feet away from it um so i
have been shot
at and then another time a guy was
riding up the road that i
had my tent on and he was on a bicycle
and he had i seen his arm go around his
back
and i seen his arm come around and he
had a gun and he went to raise it
and i took off to the refresh center it
was early in the morning people were
just starting to gather
and i jumped in the crowd which was
completely [ __ ] hateful like
like shitty of me because i jeopardized
the number of other people's lives
in the event that this crazy ass wanted
to shoot into the crowd to try to get me
so i jeopardized a lot of people and i'm
if you're watching this and you knew
about it i'm sorry
uh first mentality
the first thought that comes to mind
when somebody's running after you with a
gun
is [ __ ] run and try to hide yeah or
blend
and yeah i jeopardize other people's
lives i'm so sorry and i've
i i'm run i've seen you run you run fast
yeah
i did i run i ran i ran i key i'm always
running
um and uh it makes no [ __ ] sense for
me to stay here
what am i doing i don't know but i'm
here and i can't leave i can leave but i
don't want to leave i want to leave but
i'm not
leaving i don't know it's crazy
i make no sense uh
people shouldn't do what i'm doing um
because
it's just not it's not smart and uh
we all know what the end result's gonna
be if i keep playing this game
um eventually eventually uh
the big bad wolf's gonna catch up with
me uh you know
karma's a [ __ ] right and i'm not trying
to
i'm not trying to provide my family with
that end result
and i got my mother who has been worried
sick about me i haven't been able to
contact for two months
and after a month and a half she finally
uh just got a hold of me a couple of
days ago
my phone was stolen uh three four weeks
i don't know [ __ ] four weeks ago on
in the subway so i have no connection to
the outside world
and you'd think that it would be
relatively simple to ask someone
anyone when there's a million phones on
the street
can use your phone for a minute nobody
wants to let you use their phone
no and if you ask to use their phone
that's like saying
i [ __ ] your mother they want to beat
your ass because you asked to use their
phone
it's like do you [ __ ] know me like
you
you think i'm gonna let you use am i
it's crazy people people people
people are mean here like there's
there's there's
some good people and there's a lot of
really mean people and
everybody wants to fight like people are
just people are out of their [ __ ]
mind here
and i just i don't know like i i wish i
had a
psychology major i'd love to [ __ ]
understand the the
the psychology behind the craziness here
because
everything's so crazy here i think i
think it's rubbed off on you every
has it you're still i'm not trying to be
crazy i'm
man i think it's turning me crazy i just
i'm just so
this is a culture shock like they're
there's nothing let me give you
something
i'm gonna take you to the bus station
i'm gonna give you money i'm gonna get
you a ticket rather than giving you
money for a ticket
and get your ass out of here would you
would you get on that bus
probably not probably not yet all right
we'll figure it out i need a little more
excitement first
but yeah i just this is i mean if if
you're from the east coast i don't know
if you're from
any city that doesn't have skid rows
tent cities
[ __ ] like this this is bizarre
this this this
california man wow it's crazy here this
this is
there's nothing compared to in the whole
[ __ ] world i've been everywhere this
is this is crazy i i can't compare to
nothing this is
unlike anything i've ever seen in my
life uh i mean
uh seeing women running around
men women running around in the streets
naked cops are driving by they're not
stopping
they're not they're not bothering them
they're not they're not saying hey
go get some [ __ ] clothes on hey
you're under [ __ ] rest hey
you can't be [ __ ] naked in the street
they're just they drive by
they are some chicks [ __ ] men walking
down the road but that's naked it's just
this is normal [ __ ] here what like this
no it but it's bizarre it don't make no
sense uh
and it's like every [ __ ] word people
are doing drugs in corners everywhere
the cops are driving by they see it i
know they see it
they have to see it their drug deal is
going around in front everything is
everything this is total [ __ ] anarchy
there is no
police control they have there's you're
allowed to do anything you want you
could
you could literally how do i say it
appropriately
without being part of crazy california
you can do
anything in the street i mean no limits
anything in the street
anything in front of a cop i would say
accept murder
possibly and you will get away with that
you're not going to bother you
this is the craziest life i've ever seen
in my life i think that's why i can't
leave which
i'm just every [ __ ] day every moment
of the day
everything i see every moment of every
day
is just so bizarre i i'm just beyond
fascinated i can't believe
that all this there's no [ __ ] limits
and i i'm just fascinated
you're hooked to an extent yeah
it's not going to be the end result i
had it it can't be i
i have to escape it eventually but i
just i just i it's
so you know it's like it's like a kid
being homeschooled
their whole life being sheltered by
their parents and then being thrown into
the city
new york city being being raised in a
little country bump town
in in a homeschool never leaving the
house till you're 18
never meeting a woman never meaning an
african-american never meeting
whatever and then going and being thrown
into new york city
[ __ ] california and uh and then
you're being exposed to all this
it's so bizarre it's addicting it's like
i it's almost you can't get enough but
then it's like it's too much
and it's it's i i i i'm lost for words i
it's it's just amazing crazy i hope you
figure out a way out man
yeah please pray for me pray for me and
please
please pray that on the kills and please
pray i survived this
and if you're watching this don't come
here
if you if you've if you're fascinated by
uh the bizarre [ __ ] i mean come but get
out of here quick
don't stare all right elijah thank you
so much
you